You know how your mom told you to eat your
broccoli?
She was right - better eat it(!) or you gon'
die.
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
I'm not ashamed to admit it!
Broccoli is one of my all time favorite vegetables.
And now there's an excuse to eat 25 pounds
of them per day....well, approximately.
You may have seen Trace's video he did awhile
back about how China is one of the most polluted
countries in the world.
The World Health Organisation recommends that
cities not exceed a particulate matter 2.5
concentration of 25 micrograms -- these are
the particles that can penetrate deeply into
your lungs and enter the bloodstream.
Beijing's concentration....is over 500 micrograms.
The Shanghai Academy of Social Sciences report
that Beijing's pollution is so bad, it's almost
uninhabitable by humans.
Rough times you guys.
But now, broccoli is coming to the rescue.
Research from Johns Hopkins on 300 men and
women in rural China found that by drinking
a beverage with broccoli sprouts every day,
they can excrete some of the pollutants through
their urine.
Compared to their control group, the group
that was drinking of the broccoli sprout drink
excreted 60% more benzene out with their pee
-- and 23% more acrolein!
Benzene is a known carcinogen, it has been
linked repeatedly with leukemia and other
blood-related cancers.
Acrolein, on the other hand, is a chemical
that causes irritation of the respiratory
tract.
It may also cause cancer, scientists don't
know for sure.
The drink might even help secrete other pollutants
as well, scientists just studied these two
because they are the most stable molecules
-- good for tracking.
They found that throughout all 3 months of
the study, the benzene and acrolein excretion
stayed the same too, so it wasn't just a one
time thing.
How is it that broccoli sprouts are able to
work this wizardry?
Broccoli contains glucoraphanin , which, when
you eat it, creates another compound called
sulforaphane.
Sulforaphane signals enzymes in your body
to get to work, breaking the pollutants down
to be washed out through your urine.
Unfortunately, scientists think that sulforaphane
only breaks down chemicals you've JUST been
exposed to, so it may not be very helpful
for pollutants, pesticides, and other nasty
junk that are already lingering in your fat
cells.
Scientists have also observed indirect antioxidant
effects with sulforaphane -- the enzymes it
catalyzes can block chemicals in the body
from becoming carcinogen.
It's kind of magical isn't it?
EAT THIS...PEE THIS OUT.
Sometimes I'm just in awe of the human body
and all these complicated chemical processes
that are going on inside of us ALL THE TIME.
And all you gotta do to amp it up...is eat
your broccoli.
Thanks for joining me for DNews everyone.
And if you're looking for another interesting
tidbit, check out Trace's new TestTube Daily
video about what the autism spectrum ACTUALLY
consists of.
In the mean time - what's your FAVORITE vegetable?
Tell me about it down below and I'll see you
next time!